As long as you're clear about your goals, you're gonna succeed.
We've got a collective responsibility...
...to make sure that you're getting those opportunities.
And there are resources out there that we've got to pull in to the school center.
Businesses, foundations around the country,...
...they wanna fund more career connect programs 'cause it's in their interest.
When you can say,....
..."Hey, the math that I'm doing here could change the way the business operates,"...
...or "I see how this biology experiment could help develop a drug that cures a disease,"...
...that's a door opening in your imagination.
It's also good for our economy, it's good for our businesses.
That's a new career path you're thinking about.
It allows you to pursue higher education in that field...
...or the very training you need to get a good job,...
...or create a new business that changes the world.
That's good for our economy.
It's good for business, it's good for you.
It's good for America.